(map thumping)
- This is Putin's war
seven months on.
(dramatic music)
I've been looking at this map
every day, tracking this war.
This war that has led
to seven million people
fleeing this country,
thousands dead, including
countless civilians.
I wanna show you what's going
on kind of in the macro,
a time lapse of this war.
(dramatic music)
And I also wanna look at my predictions
back at the beginning of the war.
- Russian invasion of Ukraine.
- What I thought this map might look like,
and I wanna compare it to
how it's actually played out.
I've been watching the video I made
from right before the invasion,
remembering a world where
this hadn't happened yet.
I'm not sure that he's
gonna invade tomorrow,
but he very well could.
So let me quickly get you up to speed
on what seven months of
war has meant for Ukraine,
to show you what the new
strategy is for Russia
and who's actually winning this conflict.
- [Presenter] Russian troops
are moving in (indistinct)
- Hey, pause really quick.
I need to thank today's sponsor,
and I'm quite excited actually
because today's sponsor is Climate Power.
There's a big thing happening
in our country right now,
which is that a new law was passed
that is like the biggest, most significant
climate impact law that is
now the law of the land,
it actually passed.
It's a huge deal.
And the reason why it passed in part
is because of the pressure
from young people.
Young people who are going
to inherit this earth
are taking serious action
to fight climate change.
Luckily, this is just the beginning.
Climate Power is an organization
that makes it very easy for
you to find out how to vote.
There are over 8 million new young voters
eligible for this
midterm that's coming up,
and most of them will not vote
just like based on the data.
So please prove the data wrong.
Make a plan to vote if you don't have one.
Most states have like early voting.
It's actually very doable,
and it feels really good.
Like it feels really good to vote
and know that you're actually
like fighting for change.
Climate Power isn't selling you anything.
Literally, it is there
to make it super easy
to register to vote, to
find your polling places,
to learn how to vote
early if you wanna do that
so you don't have to
go to a polling place.
In short, it makes it easier for you
to have your voice heard
as a young person who probably won't vote.
There are a lot of candidates running
who don't care about climate change,
who don't think it's a real problem
and that's why this is important.
It is so important
that Climate Power is
sponsoring today's video
and I am so on board with that.
So thank you Climate Power
for sponsoring this video
and supporting my channel.
But seriously, the passage of
the Inflation Reduction Act
is the beginning.
We have momentum, let's keep it up.
So go to votefuture.org to
quickly register to vote
and to find out what you can do
to really affect this election.
And check the links in my description
that bring you to Climate Power
where you can learn more
about what you can do
to actually have your voice heard.
Okay, let's get back to another
very important global issue,
the war in Ukraine.
(jet engine roaring)
(missile explosion)
(people speaking in foreign language)
- Okay, quick reminder that this invasion
that happened in February
was really just an escalation
of a war that's been going on over here
in the eastern part of
Ukraine for eight years.
- [Presenter] The Russian military
now being directly involved
in fighting Ukrainian government forces.
- [Presenter] Russian troops spreading out
throughout the strategic
Crimean peninsula.
(Putin speaking in foreign language)
- It was back in 2014 that Putin invaded
and occupied and then annexed,
which basically just
means stole this peninsula
called Crimea.
That sparked a war that has
been going on in this region,
the Donbass region for eight years,
where Ukrainians who
sympathized with Russia,
rose up trying to fight to
become a part of Russia.
(Putin speaking Russian)
- And then, as we all
know, earlier this year,
I mean, you know what happened.
(ominous music)
Putin moved in from all sides,
except for the West, of course.
His big goal was to swiftly
take the capital of Kyiv.
You gotta take the capital if
you want to win a war quickly.
The scariest images
at the beginning of the
war if you remember,
were these 60 kilometer long convoys
of Russian military
vehicles in these huge lines
moving towards the capital.
60 kilometers long.
I mean, these images were so striking.
I frankly thought Putin was
gonna be victorious in this.
I thought he was going
to take the capital.
But this plan very much did not work.
- We are seeing Russians
slowly getting closer to Kyiv.
- [Presenter] Ukrainian forces
are continuing to hold their
capital from the Russians.
- This was Putin's first
big miscalculation.
He way overestimated his troops' ability
and way underestimated
the response of Ukrainians
and the West who pumped loads
of weapons into the country
to help them fight.
Not only did the Russian
army fail to take Kyiv,
the Ukrainian army
mounted a very effective
counter offensive and pushed Russia
out of all of this territory
in the course of just a few weeks.
After this giant defeat,
Putin calls all of his
troops back to regroup
and to focus on a more
narrow front of the war.
Sticking to over here,
the plan was now to continue to liberate
the eastern regions of the country
that already had a lot of
pro Russian separatists,
who again, had been fighting
here for eight years.
And as the summer approached,
I think this is where a lot
of us like started to tune out
because the war turned into
a long protracted stalemate,
with some occasional Russian gains
and a few counter offensive
from the Ukrainians.
The term we need to use
here is war of attrition.
Basically, who can wear
down the other first
through destruction and endurance.
This is a horrible way to fight a war.
And while Putin's attempt
to take over Kyiv failed,
He didn't fail in taking over
other major population centers.
Like here in Kherson,
which was the first major
city to fall to Russia
after the invasion.
- The battle for Kherson in
particular is intensifying.
- Watching how they treat
their first conquered city
is a really good indicator
of what Russia's real goal is here.
They didn't just occupy the city,
they got busy turning it into Russia.
They took down the Ukrainian flag
and replaced it with a Russian one.
They put up these creepy
billboards with like young children
about Russia being one people,
and Russia is quote, "here forever,"
like super on the nose on
what they're trying to do.
The brave people of Kherson
gathered and protested
like right next to Russian tanks,
but they didn't stop
the Russians from doing
what they clearly had been
planning this whole time.
On May 1st, Russia
announced that these people
would start using the Russian ruble,
like the Russian currency.
They seized control of the broadcasting
and internet channels
and stopped these people
from being able to connect with the world.
These events are a big deal
because Putin said he was
invading to liberate these people,
a special military operation,
not to conquer them.
Putin was unable to oust the government
and initiate a regime change
to put in a government
that would've been more
friendly to Russia.
So now it looks like he's gonna
try to gobble up the country
from the east piece by piece.
And the keyword here is annex.
(missile launching)
- Russia has launched an
intense ground campaign
to capture a key Ukrainian city
in the Eastern Donbass region.
- Annex is a super benign
like technical word,
but it means to conquer
land to then occupy it,
and then to just unilaterally declare
that this land is a part
of our sovereign territory.
No treaties, no nothing,
just a unilateral land grab.
So let's rewind to the
beginning of the war.
Watch how at the beginning it
was all about this invasion
from all three sides, a
very aggressive invasion,
again with the focus on the capital.
But once Russia got kicked out of Kyiv,
the war really starts to
become focused on all of this.
But Russia made progress.
They took over all of
these population centers
here in the Donbass region,
and by the end of April,
it was starting to become
clear what the next move was.
It came out in Russian
media in this report
that a senior Russian military official
said that the next phase
of the operation was quote,
"To establish full
control over the Donbass
and Southern Ukraine regions.
And then he says it point blank,
he says that this will allow Russia
to establish a land bridge
from mainland Russia
all the way to Crimea,
this peninsula that
Russia annexed in 2014.
But why stop there?
This Russian military
commander then infers
that the next part of the plan
is to create that land bridge even further
all the way to Transnistria,
this little sliver of a pretend country
that basically no one recognizes
and that should be a part of Moldova,
but that is full of Russian soldiers
and a bunch of people who
want Russia to annex them.
Establishing this part of the land bridge
would be pretty difficult,
because it would mean a battle in Odesa,
which is Ukraine's third largest city.
There'd be a horrible fight,
so let's just hope that part of the plan
does not come to fruition.
But Russia has been successful
in deeply establishing this land bridge
between their country and Crimea,
but to do that, they had to
fight a very bloody battle
in the port city of Mariupol.
- [Presenter] We begin tonight
with the battle for Mariupol.
- [Presenter] The mayor of Mariupol
is calling on residents to evacuate.
- After an egregious few weeks,
Russia finally took over the city.
- [Presenter] Thousands of
civilians remain in Mariupol.
- So yeah, that's the phase of the war
that we are in right now.
More and more evidence is mounting
that Russia isn't just planning to occupy
and liberate these people,
but to actually annex them
to be a part of Russia.
US intelligence reports claim
that Russia is installing
Russian officials
to lead these cities and regions.
They're creating these fast
tracks for Russian citizenship
and making it so that all new
babies born in these regions
are automatically Russian citizens.
Any day now they're
gonna hold fake elections
to gauge if the people want to be Russian.
And when you look at the results,
you're gonna see that somehow
a ridiculously giant
number of people voted yes.
This is their annexation playbook.
They've done it before and it's worked,
and it looks like they're doing it again.
- Annexation by force
would be a gross violation
of the UN charter
and we will not allow it to
go unchallenged or unpunished.
- But the Ukrainians are fighting back.
They have not surrendered to this army
that is way more powerful than they are.
As we're making this video,
there is a giant counter
offensive happening up here,
and the Ukrainian army is
taking back huge swaths of land.
The New York Times pointed out
that Ukraine captured
more territory in a week
than Russia had captured in five months.
If you watch the videos
of the Ukrainian soldiers
liberating these cities,
it's pretty emotional.
And if we're looking at the
map thinking strategically,
it's an important reminder
of what the spokesperson
of the US National Security Council said.
- And we would remind Mr. Putin
that over time may prove
unable to hold this territory.
- And this gets to the last
point I want to make here.
I'm here to argue that he's already lost.
Back at the beginning of this
war I made this prediction
thinking that Putin
was gonna be successful
in taking the capital and
overthrowing the government.
All logic pointed that he
was capable of doing that,
but he clearly did not.
I was wrong.
Instead, Putin has been able
to control a few strips of land
in the east and the south.
He's got his landbridge to
Crimea and he may keep going,
but again, Putin's war,
the motive and the goal
is based on some pretty giant delusions,
chief among them that he
is liberating these people
who are ready to come
back to the Russian flock.
That is not what is happening
and we have seven months
worth of war to prove it.
(upbeat music)